Oh
well it looks like I'm the only one who
couldn't get into the original Santa
Clause movie as they made not one but
two sequels to this film both with Tim
Allen reprising the role how do they
hold up well I guess like the first
Santa Clause there's some elements
they're really magical unique and nice
while other moments are painfully
predictable and extremely boring and
well do they balance out well that
depends which one you're looking at in
Santa Claus - the mrs. Claus Tim Allen
has to find himself a wife and get
married or else all the powers of Santa
Claus will disappear and of course being
typical Disney he only has a month to do
it and convince her to marry him
ah like that makes this really
stupid but what makes it good are some
really genuinely romantic elements and
yes it's still done in a month and
that's weird but if you look at
everything else as kind of this first
date and just a couple slowly falling in
love then actually it's not that bad he
tries courting a principal at a school
that first he thinks is really
cold-hearted but the more he talks to
her the more he realized that there's
actually more to her than he thought and
their chemistry I think is totally
believable and really charming and leads
to a lot of very nice romantic moments
but guess where it leads that's right he
has to tell the truth about who he is
she gets angry and doesn't believe him
and it all starts over again we saw it
in the first film it wasn't good then
why are we watching it again but to the
movies credit there's a subplot about a
robot Santa who is taking over the North
Pole and it's surprisingly really funny
let me rephrase that it's so awkwardly
acted that you can't help but find it
funny and I don't know if that was
intentional or not but it actually does
get a giggle out of me
but then he got sit through another
subplot about his son being put on the
naughty list which really you don't need
you could have cut this and everything
would have been fine and he also had to
sit through some incredibly unfunny
moments where Tim Allen seems like a
jerk and is really annoying but then at
other times he seems really charming and
really nice and that other moments the
comic relief can be really funny at
other moments they can be really not
funny and oh it's just all over the
place
but for me though I at least give the
movie credit that's trying something
different for the most part there's
another clause and there's another
mission but at the same time we see more
of the North Pole and we see some really
nice Christmasy moments and we see Santa
Claus actually being really charming and
yeah Tim Allen actually is turning out
to be a very unique kind of Santa Claus
it's still Tim Allen but yeah he sort
gives it his own spin so I did find
myself actually liking it enough because
yeah there's enough unique things to it
the third one on the other hand is a bit
of a different story this one's called
the escape clause and we have Martin
Short come in as Jack Frost who's trying
to totally dethrone Santa and take over
his job well that's all fine and good
but we have a subplot where his wife
wants to bring her parents up but they
can because they don't think they can
keep a secret so they tried to convince
him that it's Canada well okay that's
kind of funny that can work but then we
have yet another sub Y with her about to
give birth and yet another subplot about
him being too busy and yet another
subplot that's combining like three
different movies where he goes back in
time and it's like he never existed as
Santa and what does that mean so we sort
of have Back to the Future and it's a
wonderful life and the other Santa
Clause movies and any other movie you
can throw in here that's not entirely
original there's still some strong
elements like I enjoy how a lot of
machines making the toys break down so
he has to make the bits of the toys that
are still around into one other toy a
brand new toy that's actually pretty
cool again it's showcasing how the Tim
Allen personality could actually make an
OK Santa Claus but the parents are
miserable characters most the time has
just spent with people being unhappy not
getting many labs even Martin Short is
really underplayed in his comedy but the
designs are still really nice and I
really enjoy these enchanted side
characters like the Easter Bunny and
Father Time and stuff like that they're
a good dish in the second film and they
make much more of an appearance here and
I really like but for me there's just
not enough fun to it or comedy so yeah
on the whole I actually would kind of
recommend the second one if you can get
through some of the but the
third one just has too much for
me I give credit that they tried to do
something new with the idea and at least
try to evolve it and when it works it's
great but when it doesn't it's a pretty
awkwardly annoying
dismiss but hell if your christmas
junkie like me you're gonna see it
anyway so check it out and draw your own
conclusions